all right meantime healthcare workers
and first responders across America
struggling get the critical protective
gear they need in some places my next
guest jumped into action when her
district needed help getting n95 masks
sawed off firsthand how hard it is to
get a hold of some of these crucial
medical supplies Michigan congresswoman
Alyssa tslot kenaz a member of the House
Homeland Security Committee she joins us
now congressman we appreciate you coming
and talk about the process you know
we've seen some areas where this
protective gear has now come in it
appears that our health care workers on
the front lines are getting what they
need but it takes a lot of work as you
know first hand yeah and I say it's
pretty spotty there are areas where
maybe the equipment is coming in I still
know that there are hospitals here in
southeast Michigan who simply do not
have enough equipment and I've spoken to
just tons of health care providers who
are in the ICUs who are into baiting
patients every day and they're using
equipment that their brother got them or
that someone lent them so I don't think
it's easy to say that everyone has the
equipment that they need but it's a bit
of a Wild West scenario particularly
because so much of our supply chain on
medical equipment and medical gear we
now know really comes from China and
it's been a really difficult experience
going through the process of getting a
hold of a guy who has relationships in
China with a factory places the order
the delays the customs the Chinese
government getting involved with
middlemen it's really been like the Wild
West well on that point that last point
about the supply chain from China we've
heard Republicans like Lindsey Graham
say that they're working with President
Trump to change that the president's
been taking on China practically since
day one of his administration remember
going back to the campaign you know you
know as a Democrat I don't agree with
them on a lot but is this something when
this pandemic is through and when we
feel like we finally have our arms
around it do you think this is something
both parties can work on and say this
supply supply chain a stranglehold by
China really doesn't make sense for
America yeah I do and honestly I mean I
just introduced a piece of legislation
called the made in America supply chain
initiative it won't help us with today
but the the goal is that we will never
again be hamstrung by all of our
supplies coming from foreign country
when it's really so important for
certain items so I think this is
absolutely an area where there's overlap
there's a bunch of Republicans
interested in co-sponsoring my bill I
want it to be bipartisan because I don't
think anyone wants to beholden beholdin
to another country in order to get our
nurses the masks that they need that's
crazy and I'm from the Pentagon right I
used to be at the Pentagon and there's a
very clear by American provision in law
on military equipment because we never
wanted to depend on another country for
our military hardware we should have
those same by American provisions on
medical supplies absolutely a bottom
line on your state we've been checking
in all around the country the governor
here Andrew Cuomo says the worst is over
in New York we checked in with
Republican Steve Scalise earlier in this
program he said Louisiana is flattening
the corrupt Michigan as you know better
than I has been particularly hard-hit
are you flattening the curve there well
we're in our worst two weeks and the
truth is they just had reports come out
that we've had more deaths per capita
than anywhere in the country we're at
literally hopefully the tip of our curve
and then hopefully gonna come back down
I do think some of the aggressive action
that we took in the state led by our
governor is flattening the curve but
there's no doubt that we're in the thick
of it and you just have to listen to my
phone's ringing off the hook from our
medical professionals that they're in it
right now they're really internet is
traumatizing for a lot of them
absolutely you just mentioned the
governor Gretchen Whitmer as you know
better than I she's faced a lot of
criticism for some of those measures
she's been taking for example saying
Michigan there's can't go to their
second homes these are not rich people
necessarily these are folks going to a
lake home or a cottage as you know they
can't go to that home other people as
stores are being told you can't sell
paint somehow and folks are saying how
does stopping the sales of paint how
does that help you with the coronavirus
as some of us gone too far I mean listen
I think that there will be people who
are alive in a few months because of the
aggressive action that our governor took
and there's always gonna be Monday
morning quarterbacking whenever you're
in a crisis and you have a leader making
decisions it's going to draw criticism
um no one likes that we can't go up
north and in Michigan everybody goes up
north no one likes that we can't go to
our lawn and garden stores but we didn't
do that in an arbitrary way we we say
you can't go up north because if you
happen to have the virus we don't want
to spread it to our communities up north
there's a medical reason for much of
this now it's not that we don't want
people buying paint it's that the place
where they congregate and buy paint
allows for more transmission and we all
want to get back to work that is
everything we're talking about right now
but we have to let the medical piece
guide us because the worst case scenario
can you imagine if we get back to work
and then suddenly viruses the virus
spreads again and we have a second wait
we have to kill this thing as much as
possible and I know she's taking some
hits obviously she's gained in
prominence and so she's going to be an
easy target but when you're a leader
you're taking aggressive action I think
should be rewarded not sort of Monday
Morning Quarterback
right last 30 seconds we have though you
mentioned you worked at the Pentagon you
were CIA analysts as well you had to
work within the frameworks of the
Constitution obviously and there are
protesters now in your state saying the
governor has violated the Constitution
in their eyes and and and gone after
some of their fundamental freedoms
you're responsible well that's their
right to protest and they can certainly
do that I really hope that they stay in
their cars and they don't congregate but
listen like every other governor in the
state the governor has taken actions
based on the authority that she has just
like in New York or Louisiana or any
other place it doesn't violate their
constitutional rights to be
forward-thinking about public health and
again think of the human beings that
we're trying to help here not just
people who could say but the people
working on the front lines literally of
America's latest war in those healthcare
communities in the hospital's we're
trying to make sure those hospitals
aren't overrun and to support where we
can our frontline workers and that's
what we all be thinking about
all right well those health care workers
are heroes we've been talking about them
you're one of the lawmakers have been
trying to get them what they need
Melissa Scott slot can we certainly
appreciate and we're still thinking
about your state as well thank you thank
you